we know
father
everyone knows
just look at them
hey guys Pete here today I'll be talking
about episode 7 of House of the Dragon
which delivered some major incidents
that book readers knew were coming but
still managed to be surprising by
changing the details of the way it
played out things are escalating quickly
as we near the end of the first season
and driftmark sets the stage for the
rest of the series so much happens in
this episode that's all in service of
these two big events Eamonn losing his
eye as he claims the biggest baddest
dragon in Westeros and the aftermath of
that and this new Union between the heir
to the iron throne and her bad boy uncle
and it all works to create a point of no
return for these main characters there's
also a lot happening on the side that
will probably be wise to remember
aegon's heavy drinking Helena playing
with a spider and repeating things like
full of green full of black dragons of
Flesh weaving dragons of thread there's
also the fact that these two are now
betrothed remember when everyone
discredited Otto's idea of having him
marry his half-sister raniera well it
turns out he'll just be marrying his
full sister instead no half measures
there for him Laris is still hanging
around and offering up his services to
the queen as much as she's on the Alps
with her Targaryen counterpart she's got
herself some guys between him and
Kristen Cole that are both willing to go
to Great Lengths to make sure she has
what she needs they were practically
tripping over each other to cut out a
child's eye viserys is still
deteriorating and Damon still doesn't
want any help from him but they do have
a short conversation for what we can
expect is the first time in years and
Otto has returned to his role as hand of
the king and from what we see the years
have not tempered the feelings between
him and Damon the episode opens with a
funeral we see Lena's body return to the
attack Eternal Waters off of the coast
of driftmark this has brought everyone
together and they've all got something
going on remember Lena died in the last
episode by Dragon after complications
during childbirth so the belarians are
all dealing with that but we also lost
Lionel and Harwin strong so rhaenyra and
her kids are dealing with that there was
one smaller moment here that stood out
as encapsulating how the early part of
this show is essentially a sequence of
bad decisions and missed opportunities
Eamon walks up to this Brazier at the
same time Jace does and isn't able to
come up with anything to say so he just
walks away it looked like there was
something inside of him that was telling
him to say a kind word or offer some
support they are being raised together
they do know what's going on in each
other's lives generally but they both
recoiled when they were confronted with
his uncomfortable situation and based on
what happens later it does feel like it
was the last chain chance for things to
go differently the funeral is a somber
occasion for all involved and as viserys
is going to bed he accidentally calls
Allison Emma which is his first wife's
name and it's a great illustration of
just how disconnected this family is
from each other and how the thing that's
keeping them together is falling apart
right in front of them after he's gone
Otto grabs up a nearly passed out aegon
and sends him to bed Carl retrieves
Lenor at corliss's behest and does the
same with him and from there everyone
goes their separate ways
rainies and Corliss have a very
interesting conversation behind closed
doors she wants her husband to honor
Lena by naming Bayla the heir to
driftmark she talks about blood and how
raniera's sons are not theirs but he
doesn't want to cast more doubt on their
legitimacy because that would undermine
the power that he's worked so hard to
Cobble together and his authority his
wife is more concerned with the personal
she comes straight out and calls them
bastards and this leads to him saying
that history doesn't remember blood it
remembers names which is in line with
what she said about him and his concern
with the Legacy above all this ties
together perfectly with the last
conversation we saw between them when
they were worried about lane or marrying
rhaenyra and I love the dynamic they set
up between these two where she's able to
identify his motivations better than he
is even if here he's not interested in
hearing her and following her lead
Damon and raniero walk on the beach and
catch up where she reveals a little more
information about her relationship with
Elena apparently they tried to have
children but it didn't work she says
there was no joy in it so she found that
in her relationship with Harwin the
conversation turns to the how and the
why of him leaving her all those years
ago when she was still a child even
though they both admit that they got
something out of their relationships
with Harwin and Lena he says that they
were happy enough she says she enjoyed
the being desired of it all and that she
did trust him and even laments that she
should have stopped him from returning
to harrenhal but you still get the sense
that they both have been holding on to
this idea of being together while all of
that was going on she brings up the
curse of harrenhal which is something
larus mentioned Alison in the previous
episode and it is an interesting bit of
lore that I won't get into here other
than to say that several powerful houses
that inhabited that castle have gone it
distinct Damon calls that a ghost story
and steers the conversation towards the
politics of what we're all starting to
sense is going to happen between these
two he throws out the idea that he
wouldn't be surprised if Otto and
Allison would use the story of the curse
to their advantage which is to say that
they might kill the hand of the king so
that he could take his position back but
at this point renera doesn't believe the
queen is capable of cold murder he
responds that each of us is capable of
depravity more than you would believe
which feels like it could serve as
foreshadowing but also highlights the
fact that there's a lot that they don't
know about each other which in his case
includes things like killing his first
wife Ria Royce with all that out of the
way it finally happens this time they
actually go through with the coupling
and it looks like they both are very
pleased with the results in the meantime
Eamon takes his chance and claims vegar
which played out a lot differently than
it did in the book and is much improved
for TV in my opinion there's so much
tension in his approach and it's in the
back of our minds that this giant dragon
has also just put its last Rider out of
her misery in the book he was spotted by
the kids on his way to do this so he
essentially jumped on just to avoid
getting caught and here we see that he
negotiates in a sense after vegar isn't
keen on his approach in the beginning he
keeps it together he straps in for a
harrowing ride that he eventually gets
the hang of and the experience leaves
him feeling like he's something special
all the weirdness and insecurities he
felt around the other kids is washed
away and he emerges a dragon rider where
it seems notable that this is a
Targaryen achieving what they believe to
be their Birthright Bela and Reina heard
this all going down and went to wake up
Jace this was their mother's dragon and
since Reyna doesn't have one yet either
she was expecting to claim her Chase
Luke and the girls confront him and
Eamon takes the chance to rub it in
their faces as if he was checking off a
list he insults everyone in the most
personal ways and when they try to come
at him he uses his age and size
advantage to smack them around a bit
they do get the upper hand briefly when
they all team up on him but that just
takes things to the next level after he
gets free he calls the boys bastards in
response to that Jace pulls his blade
and then he gets smashed in the head
with a rock and then as Eamon is
hovering over him looking like he might
actually kill him his little brother
Luke picks up the dagger and slashes him
with it after Jace throws some dirt in
his face this is all rather brutal to
watch but what I really liked about it
is the way that even in this small
Stakes Affair I mean kids fight it's a
part of growing up but when it's these
particular kids who hold these positions
in this Society things can go off the
rails pretty quick
what follows is probably the best scene
the show has put together if you zoom
out beyond the horror and Carnage of him
losing his eye the aftermath really goes
a long way to define what is happening
inside this family in the realm
currently and what this story is about
no one present in this giant room with
all these Witnesses is arguing their
position in good faith rainera learns
that Eamon called her sons bastards and
uses that to redirect viserys's anger
knowing that she can push that button in
her father and knowing full well that
it's not an untrue accusation Allison
tries to use the culture's idea that
bastards are Savage by nature to her
advantage while trying not to cross the
line that will turn her husband against
her and when he presses Eamonn it
eventually falls on aegon to save the
quiet part out loud everyone knows just
look at them this all makes me think
back a few episodes where I said that it
was interesting to see how their
families are using the these young women
as pawns and how striking it was to see
them start to explore the power that
they do have at their disposal now we
see that come full circle to where
Allison and raniera are using the king
as the pawn in the game that they're
playing this confrontation between the
families is something I've been looking
forward to seeing and the trickiest part
of it for me was always the cruelty
required to expect an eye for an eye in
a situation involving kids it's not hard
to imagine that a mother whose son has
been violently maimed might say
something impulsive and ultimately
regrettable but moving forward was
actually extracting said I yourself is
another thing entirely so this scene had
to make that work and I think it did
Alison just needs to feel that no one is
on her side and that what's happening is
completely unjust she has to have the
feeling that things are slipping away
from her in a way that it makes her
desperate if you go back and re-watch
you'll notice that Olivia Cook does a
fantastic job of expressing how this is
building up over the conversation when
it all boils over it's not so much
exposing who she really is as renera
implies later but her breaking under the
weight of the circumstances the show is
telling us that she's lost her mind in
that moment and while that in no way
makes what she tried to do okay it does
work to make the fact that it happened
it all makes sense the way that the line
that isn't sufficient lands justifies
focusing so much on these two when they
were younger in the first five episodes
and that also makes it feel a little bit
awesome when she completely unloads the
line about where is Duty where is
sacrifice it's trampled onto your pretty
foot again as that just sort of oozes
out of the dark place that she's built
up inside of her and then Rainier
returns fire with the perfect exhausting
wasn't it hiding under the cloak of your
own righteousness and renera is not
completely wrong either you can look at
all the different things that Allison
has been doing to try to undermine find
the legitimacy of her claim but she's
also playing the game there and because
they know each other she sensed that she
could push her just a little further and
that results in her getting slashed
which backs up the idea that Allison has
completely lost it they both do a
fantastic job here and as I've already
mentioned I think this is one of the
best scenes the show's put together and
there's a part of me that thinks that
Otto and Damon kind of win this scene
the way that they both just stand off to
the side and do their internal calculus
of how they could use what's happening
to their advantage it all had a classic
Game of Thrones appeal to it in the end
viserys has said that he wants everyone
to make up and pretend like it never
happened we saw how Allison initially
responded to that but it's Eamon himself
who brings everything to a close he says
do not Mourn Me Mother it was a fair
exchange I may have lost an eye but I
gained a dragon and we know where this
is coming from on a personal level for
him but it's also a case where he did
something that is a lot more important
than he realizes for their side and this
is part of what impresses Otto he goes
to see his daughter and after she
recounts everything that was wrong with
what happened he reassures her that
they'll come out on top there will be
gossip speculating that she's gone mad
she has assured that her husband's favor
will always sort of rest on rhaenyra and
she says it was an ugly thing that she
regrets but he points out that they play
an ugly game and as much of a scoundrel
as he is she has to feel a little better
knowing that he's on her side Lenor
slept through the whole thing and he
wakes up repentant he tells raniera that
he can do better that he will do better
and they share a nice moment where he
says he hates the gods for making him
who he is but she says that she does not
he's an honorable man with a good heart
this all starts to feel like a final
scene with two characters together where
they're trying to paint one of them in
an appealing light before they get
killed off or something along the those
lines and this is where they try to pull
a Twist on people who know the source
material because in the book his story
ends with him dying as far as you can
tell there are some questions about
whether Damon might have been
responsible but it doesn't play like a
situation where he might have faked his
own death so for me as I'm listening to
rhaenyra and Damon's conversation I'm
thinking oh my God not only did they
have him killed but renera played a big
part in putting it all together I
suppose if you didn't have that
information going into this then it
might not have felt like a Twist at all
you see Damon kills some random high
tide guard him go to Carl with an offer
and then the fight breaks out all of
that doesn't really add up but rainies
and corliss's reactions do a lot of the
work of selling it of course at the same
time they're spelling out what they have
in mind in voiceover the only way they
can get married is if Lenor is believed
to be dead if that were to happen
everyone will wonder if Rainer was
behind it but that would work to their
advantage since their enemies would fear
what they were capable of the only big
problem is that the belarians will
believe that they lost their last living
child right on the back of losing Elena
as we watched their marriage ceremony
play out we're left to believe that they
decided that that was worth it and the
episode ends as we get the reveal that
it was the guard's dead body that
rhaenys cried over in the fireplace when
we see lanor escape with Carl to go live
an anonymous life somewhere across the
narrow Sea from my perspective this was
absolutely entertaining due to the
roller coaster of emotions involved in
trying to sort out the idea of rhaenyra
killing her husband after they had that
conversation it's almost a shame that
there was so much other stuff jammed
into this episode to the point that
their Valerian style wedding which
looked super interesting and the lane or
reveal feels a little shoehorned in
there at the end it did get us to where
we needed to go though in this first
season where things move relentlessly
fast I've had some problems with that
and I definitely feel like at times they
are sacrificing a lot of character
development in relation to the other
characters and to me I wondered if they
weren't sacrificing that for spectacle
and sort of expecting that to cover up
the cracks I think this episode shows
that they are capable of balancing that
out somewhat it hasn't been perfect but
I mean they do know what they have to
work with story wise and it's possible
that they're preparing to become a
different show after they get through
all the time jumps there is only one big
one left so I'm willing to withhold
judgment until we get there maybe we'll
get pilot number three next week overall
everything felt properly deranged across
the Spectrum from the kids to the adults
the way things played out it does
represent a line being crossed where
neither side can go back things have
conspired in a way that they'll have to
fight to protect what they have and
based on The Showdown we saw in this
episode that should be pretty
entertaining I mean spectacle isn't bad
in and of itself so I don't want you to
get the wrong idea when I say that there
I just hope that they're able to bring
the character-based drama in equal
measure they've managed to make Allison
somewhat sympathetic in spite of her
holier than thou stance and auto a
little more intriguing and is playing
the game to win which is no small task
as a fan of George RR Martin's work I'm
all in seeing all those dragons in one
place and then seeing Veigar flying away
at the end to see the scale of how
different they all are I mean there's a
lot of really fun stuff there for those
of us who have been reading these books
the changes have mostly been
improvements I do have some questions
about what leonor's leaving means for
his Dragon especially in an episode
where so much was made about Eamonn
bringing bagar over to their side lore
wise the dragon wouldn't take another
Rider unless their previous one one had
died so that's something that they'll
have to explain if someone else were to
claim sea smoke since Damon was already
on their side they did lose some
Firepower as far as dragons go and I
couldn't help but think about how small
raniera's kids dragons are compared to
the others that are already claimed two
of my favorite things before I wrap it
up Luke's reaction to Corliss telling
him he'll be the heir to high tide was a
great way to underline the generational
nature of what all these kids find
themselves born into and the way that
rhaenyra and Damon just casually kill a
complete innocent to pull off their plan
while it still has this feeling of oh
that's nice Lenor gets to be free as he
jumps in the boat to close things out in
this dirty game they play no one really
has Clean Hands just ask Kristen Cole
who was well on his way to removing
Luke's eye some pretty great stuff and I
think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about the episode and about
the season so far if you haven't read
the books where do you think things are
going and if you have what do you think
about the changes that we're seeing and
what did you think about the Lenoir
twist if you want to comment with some
book spoilers that's fine just mark them
and use some line breaks to make sure
they show up below the fold so that they
won't spoil anybody who hasn't read
ahead please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon